[Music]
hey you guys it's tomes of terror time
again
time to talk about another book now
i know that i said probably on the tbr
show
that i was going to have a longer gap
between
books by a single author because i
wanted to you know
give a whole bunch of different authors
a chance well i'm about to break that
role
sorry about that i think this book was
actually on my 2021 tbr
so at least i'm getting back to that
this is another book
by the wonderful wonderful grady hendrix
and this is my best friend's
exorcism from 2016. now before i take
this book away
if you are watching this on video just
take a moment
to appreciate the [ __ ] awesomeness
the radness of this [ __ ] cover look
at
it it looks like an old vhs tape and
look the back of it does too oh
i love it i mentioned before because i
also reviewed grady hendrix's other book
from 2014 which was called horror store
and that one was designed to look
exactly like an
ikea catalog and i think i mentioned on
that
that
there is there are a few things in life
that i love more
than the meeting of form and function i
guess you would say so
i really like like that thematic kind of
thing where it's like you
you know the the bulk of the story and
everything is like tied in with what the
book looks like so i really like
formatted books like that
uh so i really really love that grady
hendrix really seems to
love to do that [ __ ] as much as me now
this is the paperback edition
i will say the hardback edition is
actually pretty cute too because that is
made to look like a high school yearbook
and ins on the inside covers i don't
have it but i've seen like pictures of
it
on the inside covers all the characters
have like written it was like it was
written
in the yearbook and like some of it's
kind of laid out like a yearbook and it
is super super cute
i don't like the cover of that one as
much but i really like that they also
formatted that one and they did like a
totally different
format for both uh you know for both
paperback and hardback
i haven't seen what the kindle version
looks like so maybe they've done that in
a different way
but yeah i just [ __ ] love that and
like i said when i did horror story i
showed that too because i just love
i love like the whole thematic [ __ ]
going together like that
so as i said now before i get too much
into it
i've been reading a lot of grady hendrix
like i read horror story and i reviewed
that one a while back
while i was on vacation a week or two
ago
i also read his non-fiction book and i'm
probably not going to do a review of it
just because
it's you know it's non-fiction and i
kind of wanted to stick to fiction on
this one
but i do really highly highly recommend
it if you're into
70s and 80s horror particularly you know
literary or
paperback or rather um you know horror
books he
wrote this book called paperbacks from
hell
and it's an illustrator it's totally
illustrated it's got all these it's
beautiful full color
all kind of stuff in there and he just
went through it's like the illustrated
history of
70s and 80s paperback horror
and it is delightful um i just i read
the whole thing when i was on vacation
you know when i was like back in the
room resting
and it's just so so fun so i recommend
this one as well so like i said that's
non-fiction
but let's get back to my best my best
friend's exorcism i had seen like a
whole bunch of reviews of this
i've seen some honestly i've seen like a
couple of reviews that were kind of like
med and get it but it's like most of the
reviews are just like rapturously
adoring and i totally get it i [ __ ]
loved this book this book is one of
those things where it was like calcul
it's almost like it was particularly
calculated like
for my exact demographic the characters
in this book because it's set in
the 80s and the characters in this book
are
pretty much exactly the same age as me
so they were the same age as me in the
same year
uh you know in the 80s as this book is
set
so every single thing in here that these
two girls go through
i could totally totally relate to it
because it's just they did all the same
[ __ ] that we did
when we were kids it's just like all the
references in here so so awesome
and it just like really really took me
back to that time period like reminded
me of some [ __ ] i've forgotten about
so it was just like really really cool
in that regard so
as you may have guessed from the title
uh my best friend's exorcism this is
about
uh demon possession but that's really
not all it is
honestly i've seen this movie called or
some movie i've seen this book called
um like heathers meets the exorcist or
stranger things meets the exorcist or
something like that which is
you know kind of close um but
that's a little bit reductive i've also
seen it called a why a novel
i'm not sure if i would go that far i
can see why some people maybe got that
perception because
it is set you know in the 1980s with
characters that
are you know from it's it's from like
the six years between them being like in
uh third or fourth grade to them being
like teenagers so the characters are
young
but some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
in this like later on so i don't know
i don't know i'm sure like teenagers
will probably get a lot out of reading
this
uh particularly but like i said if you
grew up in the 80s or if you know
anything about 80s culture i'm sure it
will really like resonate with you
because i remembered every single thing
like in this video it was just like
amazing
so this tells the story of two young
girls
abby and gretchen and they live in this
town in south carolina
now abby is she's like the main
character
and she's kind of from a more like
working-class kind of background whereas
gretchen and a lot of the other
uh kids that she goes to school with are
quite wealthy you know upper middle
class
or upper class but she ends up going to
the same private school as them later
because she gets a scholarship because
she's really smart
now the book actually starts it's
interesting because it kind of starts
there's a little bit of a prologue in
the present day when abby is talking
from being in her
you know in her 40s or 50s or whatever
um and talking about
uh seeing a news story that the exorcist
has died and that kind of like kicks off
uh flashback of her talking about uh you
know the summer that her
best friend got possessed by the devil
you know we've all been there
so after that like the flashback
actually starts
in 1982 and abby is 10 years old
and there is an incident where she wants
all of the kids to come to her birthday
party at the skating rink and i loved
that because i said i think that my 10th
birthday was also a skating rink
which i thought was like really really
funny i was like oh my god i think that
totally was
i could maybe my ninth made may 11th i
can't really remember but i totally had
one of those two birthdays at skating
rink so i totally like
i got into the whole thing and a lot of
the songs that were playing and [ __ ]
like that it was just like so so funny
but it turns out that after she's
invited everybody to the class to her
birthday party
then this kind of rich [ __ ] kid
margaret she invites everybody in the
class to her house
to go horseback riding and obviously
nobody shows up at abby's party except
for one person
named gretchen now gretchen nobody
really
i guess she's kind of like just moved
there or she's new and like a lot of
people don't know her they think she's
weird
so abby is at first like horrified that
this weird girl is the only person that
has showed up at her party and she's
super humiliated
and then it's even worse when gretchen
gives her
like a children's bible for a present
even though
her party is very explicitly e.t themed
and she just wanted all e.t [ __ ] because
she was super super super into et
because that was the year that came out
in 1982 if you didn't know
but it so happens that after there's you
know there's a big misunderstanding abby
has like a
little you know 10 10 year old girl
nervous breakdown or whatever
but it turns out gretchen was like look
i don't want to give you the bible i
wanted to give you some cool et [ __ ] my
mom made me do this
and it turns out that they have like a
really lot of stuff in common they both
love e.t
they both love the same kind of [ __ ] so
there's a moment where they just become
like best friends
so i like that they kind of grady
hendricks starts it where the girls
met because their friendship is really
the heart of this
novel because even though this is a
horror novel
um you know and like i said some pretty
gross [ __ ] like happens later on
especially like once the exorcism starts
kind of kicking off at it's this is a
really
i don't know it's kind of hard to say
it's really in the way that if you like
stranger things or like nostalgia kind
of themed stuff like that
where horrific [ __ ] happens but at the
core of it it's just this
love between friends and it makes it
really
resonant and to be honest with you i'm
not entirely sure how
old grady hendrix is he doesn't look all
that old to me
but i will say that the characters of
abby and gretchen in this
i don't remember if i've ever read a
more
accurate or heartfelt or
it just like it really kind of resonated
these
the girls friendships like how they
thought you know what they thought about
and from that time period too
and if he did not grow up in that time
period and he's obviously not a teenage
girl
i have to say he [ __ ] nailed it i
mean he exactly knew
like what they would how they talked
like what they were how they thought
you know just the way that their
friendships developed and stuff like
that and it was just like
eerily i mean i really did feel like i
was
reading about two actual people which is
not always the case
but what i think that's really good
because that really really gets you
invested in these characters and like i
said this is another horn and it doesn't
happen that often
uh this is another horror novel where
the end of it
i don't think i'm going to spoil the end
but the end of it really kind of i
didn't cry
but it did kind of make me tear up some
because it's like a very bittersweet
it's not a sad ending necessarily but
it's a very like bittersweet kind of
ending
and a real kind of like i don't know
there's just something really about it
so like so like i said
largely this book yes it's soaked into
80s nostalgia
all of the chapters are named after 80s
songs you know like and she was or it's
the end of the world as we know it and i
feel fine or something like that
that has to do with what happens in the
chapter and there's all of that
and it does take place in the 80s but
it's not it's not like
overly done it's it's almost like it
was really i don't know if i want to say
it was set feels like it was really
written back then
but like i said he got everything
about the time period which i remember
uh quite vividly he got everything so
accurate
that it's not like you're reading
something that was written nowadays
that was you know by someone that maybe
didn't live through it if that makes any
sense
but it really did see it really does
immerse you like in that world exactly
what it was like
and everything like that especially if
you were a teenage girl and like i said
i could
kind of relate to the situation like
abby's situation you know being
kind of on the lower end of the economic
spectrum but being friends with people
that had a lot more money than you
and you know that whole dynamic and
going to a school where everyone was
much more wealthy than you
and you know so there was that whole
thing as well it was kind of a religious
school but that doesn't play
that much into it so i couldn't relate
to that because i didn't go to religious
school but you know what i mean so from
the time they meet in 1982
abby and gretchen are just like
inseparable best friends
they hang out at each other's houses all
the time um you know and everything like
that so after that they kind of
establish how deep their friendship is
how abiding their friendship is
and then they skip ahead to when they're
about 16 or they're in high school
now by this time they've kind of gotten
a little bit more
popular they have a couple other friends
margaret who was
the the [ __ ] girl from the beginning
that you know
invited everybody to her horse party and
like just made nobody come to abby's
party
so they made friends with her later and
then there's another girl named glee
so the four of them hang out together
they're they all have their own kind of
personalities and stuff but then
there there is a an incident one summer
when they're all staying i think at
margaret's
uh parents beach house or one of their
parents beach i think it's margaret's uh
parents beach house so they're staying
up there one summer
and they decide that they're going to
try lsd
now they get some from somewhere like
they steal it from someplace i don't
remember like
i don't remember the exact thing it's
not really that important
but uh so they end up taking some
gretchen is really really scared to take
it because she's
seen um you know some of the
scare-mongering [ __ ] shows that they
did back then that was just like you do
lsd once and like you're gonna be [ __ ]
up forever like sid barrett you know
what i mean
so it was that kind of thing i also want
to say too that this really works set in
the 80s because there was the whole
satanic panic
uh going on in the background and like
all this stuff about satanic cults and
everything and i think that really like
uh is really good because it informs the
whole story and how
you could see how people like believed
all these urban legends and
[ __ ] like that and they'd talk to it
it's like you guys i saw it on geraldo
it's true and you know what i mean so
there's all that kind of stuff going on
too
so they take this lsd and
the three main three girls like you know
abby and margaret and glee it doesn't
really seem to do much of anything so
maybe it was like some weak [ __ ] or
whatever
but gretchen she takes it and then she
kind of like runs off
and then they can't find her like for a
really long time and they're like
looking in the woods and they're
freaking out because they don't know if
she like had a bad trip and she took off
someplace and they don't know where she
is
so the next morning though they find her
she comes out of the woods and she's
like all naked and streaked with gore
and she doesn't really remember not
gore but mud and she doesn't really
remember what happened so
you know they don't get caught they kind
of cover that whole [ __ ] up but then
gretchen starts very slowly to change
she kind of starts acting weird she
can't remember things
she starts um not taking care of her
personal hygiene
um she starts acting real weird toward
her friends like be
really irritable really [ __ ] toward
them and all this other kind of stuff
and so there's all this kind of like
interpersonal drama going on between her
and the friends and then she starts
doing like really [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
you know trying to steal everyone's
boyfriend and like getting people drunk
that aren't supposed to be drinking and
all this other kind of stuff
so it kind of like keeps escalating and
escalating and
at some point everyone's just kind of
like you know [ __ ] her she's just
getting like
you know she's a druggie now or
something like that she's like acting we
don't want to hang out with her anymore
but abby because abby is her best friend
she knows that something
really serious has to be going on and
she is bound to determine to find out
what it is now at first she kind of
thinks you know maybe it's drugs or
maybe her
you know someone's abusing her or
something like that and then it comes
out that
or at least she thinks that maybe she
was raped when she was out in the woods
and now she's kind of acting out
um so but she really wants to get to the
bottom of it but then it turns out
that probably uh gretchen is possessed
by a demon at which point
abby like i said this is her best friend
and she loves her more than anything
so she is just going to figure out how
to fix this
and it's really it's so good and it's so
poignant because
and and i can remember this from being a
teenager too especially like you're a
teenage girl
abby really tries i mean she's just 16
like 15 or 16. she doesn't really know
that much about the world or anything
so her her attempts to like try to help
gretchen by
you know telling teachers telling her
parents telling somebody
like trying to get somebody to help her
to help gretchen
and how no one believes her or if they
turn things around and make it her fault
or something like that and it's just
this horrifying it just really like kind
of broke my heart like the whole time
because this
you really kind of get into this little
girl's character and her just like
desperately trying to
help her best friend and not really
knowing what to do and said oh well you
know i have to go to an authority figure
and they'll help me and stuff like that
and then just they're no help at all
because they just don't believe her like
i said that oh you did it you gave her
the drugs and you know get out and all
this other kind of stuff
she gets in trouble for doing all this
[ __ ] that she didn't do and it's just
like [ __ ] crazy uh escalation happens
finally in desperation she reaches out
to
this really like cheesy ass uh group
that comes to their school like for an
assembly
it's just kind of like it's and i
remember uh when this had we didn't have
this app because like i said
this this was religious school stuff but
i remember hearing about it from people
i knew that went to religious schools
they used to have these um kind of
assemblies that would go
you'd go to the assembly and then it
would be like a group that
was trying to get people like into jesus
and you know
not do drugs and everything and but then
they would have some kind of gimmick
you know what i mean so the gimmick in
this one is they're all weight lifters
so they would come out and do all these
weightlifting feats you know what i mean
like they would break cement blocks and
all this other kind of stuff and then
they'd be like
jesus let me do that all this other kind
of stuff so
now because one of the guys uh one of
the weight lifters
looks at gretchen and says i see your
demon
so abby said well he must be the real
thing so she ends up like after
you know going through exhausting every
other like possibility
she goes to him and says you know i'm
pretty sure she's possessed by a demon
and we need to help her and so that's
kind of
uh you know that kind of kicks off the
third act of the book like when he comes
to help her um
get you know get exercise and get the
demon out
so that's probably like i said i'm not
gonna spoil the end or anything but
keep in mind um this is kind of like
i think grady hendricks described it as
beaches meets the exorcist
which is accurate although i think i
think beaches
i haven't seen that in a very long time
but i think that was kind of like older
women right like female friendship stuff
this is more like and then i see it's
called heather's which is kind of
accurate too
but it's not quite as heathers or mean
girls
there is a little bit of that but so
there is a lot in there
about uh the power of female friendships
and also kind of the power
of you know female enemies like what
they can do to one another they're kind
of like psychological warfare against
one another
so a lot of the book is like that and
then just very very slowly
are these kind of supernatural elements
introduced
and then when that happens there's some
pretty gross [ __ ] in that
particularly one bar one part that i'm
thinking of with margaret
where once gretchen gets possessed she
starts
just [ __ ] with her friends just to be
an [ __ ] because she's a demon now
and she starts giving margaret who's a
little bit overweight i guess
and she starts giving her these diet
pills that her mom
had and they turned out to have like
tapeworms in them so that's a really
really
that's a really special scene when that
kind of whole thing comes to a head
so yeah it's pretty gross there's some
really gross [ __ ] uh so i will say that
it does get kind of gory and there's
like really gross like squeaky [ __ ] in
there like that
a dog does get killed so in a pretty man
that scene was kind of hard for me to
read
uh yeah so that's in there too so be
warned uh so
so it's not so much it's it's a fun book
you know and it's like i said it's very
80s nostalgia it's if you like stranger
things you'll probably be into it
and it's very much about their
friendship and all this other stuff
but there is some pretty gross and
pretty dark [ __ ] in there as well
the only really the only criticism i've
seen of it was some people didn't like
the ending either they thought the
ending was too abrupt or they thought
that it was
too sad or something like that a lot of
people didn't
well not a lot of people but some of the
people that you know that was their one
criticism didn't seem to like the ending
but i honestly um i actually quite liked
the ending uh
i i liked the way it tied up i kind of
feel like there wasn't really any other
way it could have tied up you know and i
liked that it kind of took a long view
because like i said it doesn't it
doesn't it's not so much a frame story
in the sense that
you know because at the very beginning
abby is kind of like you know it's
present day and she's reflecting back on
all this stuff that happened back in
1988
so so it doesn't really go a lot into
abby in the present day
but it does at the end of it like after
the whole exorcism
thing is resolved and after everything
happens it happens
they do kind of like um he does kind of
like cast ahead
to show like what their you know the
remainder of the lives were like
i and i actually really liked that
because like i said it made it really
poignant because the whole
the whole point of this book the whole
heart of this book is these two girls
enduring friendship and how strong it
was and how
you know they would do anything for one
another and i think that was like that
really made this book maybe like a cut
above like a lot of horror because it
really like
it really like emotionally got you
because these characters were so
vividly drawn and you know you really
you know felt a lot for them so like
when bad [ __ ] happened then you felt
really bad because they seemed like real
people [ __ ] props to grady hendricks
for writing something that
is not only that was not only funny and
horrific
and really really entertaining and page
turning
but also something that was just really
heartfelt
you know what i mean which is difficult
to do and i feel like a lot of horror
doesn't do that more of it should i
think
but you know i think that was probably
my favorite part about this book
even if there wasn't like demon
possession or anything like that i would
still think this was an amazing book
just because
the character work was so so great and
just the the friendship at the heart of
it was just so
it was just so well done and i just
really really dug it a lot
so if you really like 80s nostalgia if
you really like demon possession stuff
if you really like horror comedy if you
if you like anything
from the 80s i don't think you
necessarily have to like the 80s but it
really does help
uh you know get into the vibe of this
book
if you grew up in the 80s or if you knew
a lot about 80s like i've seen a lot of
80s horror movies and stuff like that
um then i think you will really really
dig this i just really i loved it i
thought it was fantastic
i really loved the formatting of it i
just really love the cover i just loved
everything about it i had a [ __ ]
blast
reading this book i think i might have
liked this
story wise i think i might have liked
this a little bit better than horror
story like i loved horror store also
but this one was just so much it just
brought back
so many memories for me because like i
said the characters in this
were 16 in 1988 which is about the same
age as i was in 1988
so i really related to all of the [ __ ]
that they went through when they were
kids because i was the same
age as that like it's same age as them
in the book so
it really like kind of hit a sweet spot
for me with all the 80s music and
everything like that
so if you're into that kind of stuff if
you like you know kind of funny horror
but also kind of heartfelt like kind of
sweet horror
i think you will really be into this as
well keep in mind like i said there is
some gore there is like some squeaky
parts and something bad does happen to a
dog so if that's gonna bother you
then you know maybe avoid but other than
that i just really really recommend it i
just i had a [ __ ]
great time reading it and it's super fun
and uh yeah i just really really loved
it and also
if you like that also check out
paperbacks from hell his nonfiction book
which i think came out a little bit
before that maybe 2014 2015 somewhere
around there
it's just a really really fun coffee
table book and it's written really funny
as well and it's really entertaining and
he talks about like all the
paperback horror that came out back then
that was a lot of it was batshit crazy
and it's uh super fun and he has all the
covers in there it's just really really
cool
all right so that will do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye